an organ doctor is showing a fertility
clinic for more than five million
dollars after discovering sperm he
donated resulted in the birth of at
least 17 unknown children in the lawsuit
dr. Bryce clear clearly Cleary rather
says he donated sperm at a clinic at
Oregon Health and Science University
back in 1989 he says the clinic at that
time promised no more than five children
would be conceived and that they would
be born to mothers outside of the
Pacific Northwest also his identity was
to remain anonymous
well that's not what happened Cleary
discovered through ancestry.com that he
has at least what Tony mentioned
seventeen children in addition to the
four he has with his wife the lawsuit
claims that many of these children live
in Oregon and some unknowingly attended
the same schools and churches
yikes Allison Ally says she's reached
out to Cleary after discovering he was
her father through ancestry.com knowing
that you were a product of fraud against
somebody else's emotionally overwhelming
I can't be emotionally invested in all
these people and boy Oregon Health and
Science University says in a statement
that it treats any allegation of
misconduct with the gravity that it
deserves but could not comment on the
case because of patient privacy concerns
there's so many pitfalls here because if
they're going in the same schools and
churches they could conceivably start
dating and interacting with each other
that's scary stuff so paying young
people to donate sperm or anything else
is a complicated business news I don't
know if you're equipped at 22 you need
money are you thinking about the long
term innovation and this is being
discovered over and over again now that
this that this kind of thing happened in
creating problems all over the country
yes that's something either of you ever
dude I contemplated it in college yeah I
backed away fortunately but yeah that
money is enticing we're like the only
that's the world that pays people for
that yeah okay I just want to be clear
for the record brother record